.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Das waren
die Aufzeichnungen meiner Mutter:
"Die verhängnisvolle Wanderung
Furkapasshöhe - Oberwald".
(Mann) Man sucht, findet nichts.
Man fragt sich teils auch,
ob vielleicht
ein Verbrechen passiert ist.
Ich mag mir nicht vorstellen,
dass meine Mutter zu irgendjemandem
ins Auto gestiegen ist,
der ihr etwas Böses angetan hat.
Das Schlimmste ist, dass wir den
Einsatz nicht abschliessen können.
Für mich und meine Familie hat es
am Ende keinen Unterschied gemacht.
Wir trauern genauso.
Die Wahrheit
ist wahrscheinlich eine Erlösung.
Aber wenn es
eine brutale Wahrheit ist,
ist es nicht viel einfacher
als vorher.
* Bedrohliche Klänge *
Ich hatte nur ein Foto von meiner
Mutter, ein Schwarz-Weiss-Foto.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass
meine Mutter mich sehr gerne hatte.
Auf dem Polizeiposten sagte man mir,
ich solle die Suche abbrechen.
Sie würden nicht wollen,
dass ich weitersuchte,
denn sie hätten
einen Knochen gefunden.
Dass ein Mann nicht erfährt,
dass seine Mutter
bzw. ein Knochen seiner Mutter
gefunden wurde -
dass eine solche Information
nicht weitergereicht wird,
darf einfach nicht passieren.
Ich glaube, sie lebt noch.
Ich spüre das.
* Dynamische Musik *
Ich war kein einfacher Jugendlicher.
Das Bedürfnis,
meine leibliche Mutter zu finden,
tauchte
während meiner Jugendzeit auf.
Ich glaube, meine Mutter hat mir
einfach gefehlt. Deswegen ...
Also wurde der Wunsch immer stärker,
wissen zu wollen, wer sie ist.
Als ich 16, 17 Jahre alt war,
habe ich zusammen mit einem Freund
einen Facebook-Post gemacht.
Und so startete die Suche.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt wusste ich
noch nichts über meiner Mutter,
einzig ihren Namen ...
... und dass sie damals
in Zürich lebte,
und dass man nicht weiss,
wo sie ist.
Man denkt schon sehr oft darüber
nach, was da genau passiert war
und ob es ein Verbrechen
oder ein Suizid war.
Zu meiner Überraschung
erhielt ich sehr schnell
sehr viele Hinweise
zu meiner Mutter.
"Wir kennen deine Mutter
aus der Schulzeit."
"Wir haben früher
gemeinsam Zeit verbracht."
Bis hin zu Männern,
die mal mit ihr zusammen waren.
Es wurden immer mehr,
und so hatten wir letztlich
in der Wohnung ...
Wie nennt man das?
Wenn man die Hinweise
an der Wand aufhängt?
Wie bei Detektiven in Filmen.
Ganz viele Medien fragten an,
ob sie helfen könnten.
Es nahm ein Ausmass an,
das wir nie geahnt hätten.
(Mann)
Herzlich willkommen im "Nachtcafé".
Marco Hauenstein, auch Sie hatten
keinen leichten Start ins Leben.
Bereits als Baby mussten Sie
einen mehrwöchigen Heroinentzug
hinter sich bringen.
Ihre Mutter war drogenabhängig.
Sie sind in der Schweiz
gross geworden, bei Pflegeeltern.
Ihre Mutter haben Sie gesehen,
als Sie ein Baby waren,
Ihren Vater kennen Sie gar nicht.
Als Baby
mussten Sie erst mal in den Entzug,
weil ihre Mutter heroinsüchtig war.
Wie stark waren Sie davon
auch körperlich betroffen?
Wie lange hat das angedauert?
Das spüre ich heute noch.
Ich bin auf einem Auge blind.
Das kommt wohl auch vom Heroin.
Aber ich gehe damit gut um.
Das Schicksal des 19-jährigen Marco
berührt ganz viele Menschen.
Ich glaube, dass sie lebt.
Es wäre schön,
wenn sie gefunden würde.
Mein Leben hat sich über Nacht
komplett geändert.
Es war nicht einfach,
alles durchzulesen.
Ich war damit leicht überfordert,
und trotzdem verspürte ich Glück.
Ich dachte: "Jetzt rollt etwas."
"Vielleicht kommen wir weiter
und finden sie."
Diese Zeichnung
hat meine Tochter im Kindergarten
in der ersten Woche nach dem Ver-
schwinden meiner Mutter angefertigt.
Wohl die Art,
wie Kinder so etwas verarbeiten.
Wir waren zu Hause und feierten den
Geburtstag meines zweiten Sohnes.
Am 14.9.2010 um 21 Uhr erhielten wir
die Meldung von ihrem Ehemann
an unsere Einsatzzentrale.
Um 21.15 Uhr
wurden wir von der KWRO alarmiert.
Der Kollege auf der Zentrale und ich
entschieden dann relativ schnell,
einen nächtlichen Suchflug
zu starten, da das Wetter gut war.
Wir starteten um ca. 22 Uhr mit dem
Helikopter und flogen übers Gebiet.
Wir hatten zunächst
sehr gute Bedingungen.
Und dann kam schnell der Nebel auf.
Leider musste die Suche abgebrochen
werden, weil die Nacht einbrach.
In der Nacht ist es
für den Piloten sehr schwierig,
irgendwo noch
Orientierungspunkte zu finden.
Ich war der Rettungschef hier
in der Rettungsstation Obergoms.
Wir kommen immer zum Einsatz,
wenn im Hochgebirge
oder in unwegsamem Gelände
ein Unfall passiert ist
oder Personen vermisst werden.
Dann werden wir aufgeboten,
um die Sache zu erledigen.
Am nächsten Morgen gegen 8 Uhr
war der Helikopter startklar.
Ich dachte,
wir fliegen mit dem Heli hoch
und finden die Frau
irgendwo abseits des Wanderwegs.
Das war nicht der Fall.
Die Sicht war super, wir sahen
alles Mögliche an diesem Morgen,
aber die vermisste Frau
fanden wir nicht.
Wir waren damals im Urlaub
auf Fuerteventura.
Ich hatte an dem Tag mit meiner
Tochter ein Fotoshooting am Strand.
Als ich zurück auf dem Zimmer war,
sah ich,
dass mich meine Mutter
mehrfach angerufen hatte.
Bevor wir dann essen gingen,
sagte ich:
"Geht ihr schon mal vor,
ich rufe jetzt mal Mama an
und frage, was los ist."
Mein Stiefvater ging ans Telefon
und berichtete mir,
dass meine Mutter
seit gestern verschwunden sei.
Bei Vermisstenfällen
ermittelt die Kantonspolizei
stets in alle Richtungen.
D.h., wir schliessen
auch ein Verbrechen nicht aus.
Es geht darum, die Personen,
die zuletzt mit der
vermissten Person zusammen waren,
zeitnah zu befragen,
um Informationen aus erster Hand
zu bekommen.
Der Mann wurde zu Beginn
von der Polizei hart befragt.
"Meine Frau Ingeborg
war zum 15. Mal hier."
"Sie war immer im Chalet Claudia,
so wie jetzt auch."
Bei einer Befragung geht es darum,
herauszufinden,
wo sich die Person aufgehalten
und was sie unternommen hat
und ob es Anhaltspunkte gibt,
die sich mit anderen Informationen
belegen lassen.
Z.B., wenn jemand - wie im Fall
des Ehepaars Springinsgut -
das Postauto nahm.
"Um 14.15 Uhr machten wir uns zu Fuss
von der Furkapasshöhe
in Richtung Oberwald."
"Ein Weg geht am Berg lang,
ziemlich auf gleicher Höhe."
"Dieser Weg
ist nicht gross anstrengend."
Hier vorne sieht man den Weg,
ein ganz schmaler Weg.
"Er wird dann steiniger und
geht zweimal durch einen Tunnel."
"Dann kommt man an eine Verzweigung,
da steht auf einem Schild "Oberwald".
"Wir sind dann
bis zum Gipfelkreuz hochgelaufen."
"Von dem Kreuz kann man
schon runter nach Oberwald sehen."
Das erste Stück des Weges dort
ist sehr steil.
Zudem ist der Weg dort
nicht so gut gekennzeichnet.
"Meine Frau blieb dann dort stehen
und ich wollte mich
in näherer Umgebung
nach einem geeigneten Wanderweg
umsehen."
Oben beim Kreuz gibt es
eine Sitzbank mit einem Tisch.
Sie hat sich dort hingesetzt
und gewartet,
während der Mann schauen ging,
ob der Weg besser werde.
"Als ich sie nicht mehr gesehen habe,
habe ich laut nach ihr gerufen,
so laut ich konnte rief ich:
'Ingeborg!'"
Ich bin dann am Mittwochabend
in Zürich angekommen
und fuhr mit einem Mietauto
spätabends nach Oberwald.
Ich bin dann
auf der Furkapasshöhe ...
Es war dunkel,
es war gegen 23, 24 Uhr,
als ich auf der Furkapasshöhe ankam.
Ich schaute aufs Thermometer.
Es zeigte -1, -2 °C.
Da wusste ich schon,
dass das eng wird.
Bei den Temperaturen konnte
meine Mutter keine zwei, drei Nächte
ohne Jacke, Tee, Medikamente usw.
überleben.
Ich glaube, sie lebt noch.
Ich spüre das.
Ich kann das nicht erklären,
aber das ist einfach ...
Ich spüre das im Herzen.
Ich glaube, sie ist noch irgendwo.
(Mann) "Sihlquai", eine Podcast-Serie
der "NZZ am Sonntag".
Zwischen 1986 und 2007
sind zehn Frauen
auf dem Zürcher Drogenstrich
verschwunden.
Von sieben fand man die Leichen,
drei werden immer noch vermisst.
Ein Fall ist aufgeklärt,
ein Mörder verurteilt.
Alle anderen Fälle sind ungeklärt.
Wir gehen diesen Fällen nach -
wir sind This Wachter
und Christine Brand.
Marcos Fall
war einer der eindrücklichsten
von den von uns untersuchten Fällen
für diese Podcast-Serie.
Es geht einem schon nahe, wenn man
spürt, wie wichtig es ihm wäre,
zu erfahren, was passiert ist und
nicht mehr in Ungewissheit zu leben.
Ich wurde in Tegerfelden
im Kanton Aargau geboren.
Später kam ich dann
ins Heim in Zürich -
ins Monikaheim.
An die Zeit im Heim
erinnere ich mich kaum noch.
Das ist schon zu lange her.
Sie durfte mich nicht behalten,
weil die KESB meinte ...
... sie sei nicht in der Lage,
sich um mich zu kümmern.
Irgendwie so lief das.
Sie besuchte mich im Heim.
Und ...
Sie wollte mich behalten,
das weiss ich.
Aber sie durfte nicht.
Ich denke,
hätte ich ihr nicht viel bedeutet,
hätte sie mich nicht besucht.
Mit sechs Jahren
kam ich in eine Pflegefamilie
und wir zogen
ins wunderschöne Oberägeri.
Das ist meine Heimat,
hier bin ich aufgewachsen.
Ich ging hier zur Schule, meine
Freunde und Familie leben hier.
Ich habe einen Grossteil
meines Lebens hier verbracht.
Es war eine schöne Zeit,
sie waren immer für mich da.
Wir haben sehr viel zusammen erlebt,
sind viel gereist.
Ich habe relativ schnell erfahren,
dass sie nicht
meine richtige Familie sind,
sondern meine Pflegefamilie.
Und ... Das war nie ein Geheimnis.
Sie waren immer sehr offen
und direkt zu mir.
Ich erfuhr das schon sehr früh.
Sie war eine drogensüchtige,
junge Mutter.
Sie verkehrte im Milieu und war
ab und zu auf dem Strassenstrich.
Eines Nachts kam sie
nach Hause ins Haus der Mutter.
Die Mutter meint, sie habe gehört,
wie sie nach Hause kam
und später wieder ging.
Danach kam sie nie mehr zurück.
Man weiss nicht,
was mit ihr passiert ist.
Ihre Vorgeschichte - auch aufgrund
ihrer psychischen Probleme -
lässt vermuten, dass es sich auch
um einen Suizid handeln könnte.
Aber da es
gar keine Anhaltspunkte gibt ...
Sie liess auch ihr Portemonnaie
zu Hause liegen,
weshalb wohl auszuschliessen ist,
dass sie einfach abgehauen
und irgendwo untergetaucht ist.
Das schliesst man eher aus,
weil sie alles zurückliess.
Für mich
gibt es zwei mögliche Theorien:
einerseits ein Suizid,
andererseits sehe ich auch Hinweise,
dass es ein Tötungsdelikt
gewesen sein könnte.
Wenn man sich anschaut,
bei wie vielen Verbrechen der Täter
aus dem unmittelbaren Umfeld stammt,
dann ist es naheliegend,
dass man zuerst mal da fragt.
Die Polizei
sucht die objektive Wahrheit
und lässt sich nicht durch
die Gefühle von jemandem leiten.
"Sie hatte hohe Wanderschuhe
und einen roten Pullover."
"Sie trug zwei Fotoapparate mit sich.
Medikamente hatte sie keine mit."
"Sie musste solche morgens,
mittags und abends einnehmen."
"Ingeborg
musste eine Sehbrille tragen."
"Auch gestern
hat sie eine Brille getragen."
"Ansonsten hatte sie nichts mit."
Ich habe der Geschichte des Mannes
vollkommen geglaubt.
Es war eine sehr herzliche
und liebevolle Beziehung.
Ich würde sagen, traumhaft.
Es hatten sich zwei gefunden,
die zueinander passten,
die aufeinander aufgepasst haben.
Meine Mutter
war eher die starke Persönlichkeit,
die auch den Ton angegeben hat.
Und mein Stiefvater hat ihr jeden
Wunsch von den Augen abgelesen.
Er hätte alles für sie gemacht.
Undenkbar, dass er ihr
mal etwas verneint hätte.
Selbst dann, wenn es ihm unangenehm
war, hätte er es trotzdem gemacht.
Dass mein Stiefvater
etwas damit zu tun haben könnte,
war und ist für uns
nach wie vor undenkbar.
Es passt nicht zu ihm, es passt
nicht zur gesamten Lebenssituation.
Es ...
Es gab kein Motiv.
Ganz im Gegenteil, er war froh,
nach dem Tod seiner ersten Frau
eine neue Frau gefunden zu haben.
Am Anfang war er ...
... völlig fassungslos,
dass die Polizei
in Erwägung ziehen konnte,
dass er schuld sein oder seiner Frau
etwas angetan haben könnte.
Er sagte immer wieder,
er habe seiner Frau nichts angetan,
so etwas mache er nicht.
Er betonte immer wieder, dass er
keine Gewalt angewendet habe.
Tausende von Nachrichten kamen rein.
Ich ging durch die Nachrichten,
kam aber nicht mehr nach -
weder mit Lesen noch mit Antworten.
Dass Marcos Aufruf
auf ein so grosses Echo stiess,
liegt nicht daran,
dass es so viele Hinweise gab.
Ich glaube,
er hat mit seinem Aufruf -
ein junger Mann,
der seine Mutter sucht
und wissen möchte,
was mit ihr passiert ist -
viele Menschen
in ihrem Innersten erreicht.
Eine tiefe Verlustangst.
Denn die Vorstellung, dass ein
geliebter Mensch plötzlich weg ist
und man weiss nicht,
was mit ihm passiert ist,
das ist für viele
eine furchtbare Vorstellung.
Die ersten zwei, drei Tage
bin ich die Nachrichten selbst
durchgegangen und habe sie sortiert.
Später erhielt ich
professionelle Hilfe.
(Mann) Ich habe seinen Fall studiert
und fand,
dass es ein spannender Fall war
und ich ihn gerne
dabei unterstützen möchte.
Der Privatdetektiv bot mir an,
das kostenfrei zu übernehmen.
Wir übernehmen ein bis zwei
Pro-bono-Fälle im Jahr.
Es müssen Fälle sein, bei denen wir
wirklich von Hilfe sein können.
Stammen die
aus unterschiedlichen Zeiten?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Dank des Detektivs eröffneten sich
ganz andere Möglichkeiten.
... dass man ihn noch befragen kann.
Dank ihm fanden wir
verschiedene Familienangehörige -
Grossmutter, Bruder, Tante.
Ohne ihn
wäre das nicht möglich gewesen.
Als er uns den Fall schilderte,
dachten wir,
dass es eine Angelegenheit ist,
bei der wir schnell
zum Ziel kommen werden,
dass wir seine Mutter
schnell werden lokalisieren können.
Wir stellten dann fest, dass es
bereits eine Vermisstenmeldung gab.
Und dann nahm der Fall
eine komplett andere Wendung.
Dann ging es darum, herauszufinden,
was über sie aktenkundig war.
Dank meines Privatdetektivs
landeten wir dann
schlussendlich bei der Polizei
für Informationen über meine Mutter.
Durch den Druck der Medien
kam es dann letztlich dazu,
dass die Polizei und die Behörden
Informationen herausrückten.
Ohne diesen Druck
wäre das nicht möglich gewesen.
Die Polizei
meldete sich dann persönlich bei mir
und lud mich zu einem Gespräch ein.
Ich fragte sie bereits am Telefon,
worum genau es denn gehe.
Schwierige Nachrichten
überbringen wir nie am Telefon,
sondern immer persönlich.
Denn wir können sonst
nicht kontrollieren,
was mit der Person passiert,
ob sie Betreuung braucht etc.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ich bin Projektmanager für
grosse internationale Bauprojekte,
im Wesentlichen
touristische Projekte -
Hotels, Marina,
Skigebiete, Golfanlagen.
Das ist
eine zeitintensive Tätigkeit,
die aber auch sehr viel Spass macht.
Das war eine intensive Zeit, klar.
Es war sozusagen
noch ein eigenes Projekt nebenbei.
Etwas, das ich nebenbei
noch erledigen musste -
mit all den Abstimmungen und Fragen,
die alle möglichen Leute dazu haben,
berechtigterweise.
Freunde und Bekannte meiner Mutter.
Mit der Suche
ging es dann so weiter,
dass am Morgen nach meiner Ankunft
entschieden wurde,
zur weiteren Suche
sog. Gebirgsflächen-Suchhunde
einzusetzen.
Gebirgsflächen-Suchhunde
suchen die ganze Fläche
nach Gerüchen ab,
die nicht dorthin gehören.
Liegt z.B. irgendwo
ein verletzter Mensch,
passt der Geruch nicht in die Berg-
welt und der Hund reagiert darauf.
Die durchsuchte Fläche
erstrecke sich vom Furkapass
bis zum Hungerberg,
runter ins Geerental,
dann auf der anderen Seite noch
Bidmer bis runter nach Oberwald.
Also eine riesige Fläche.
Wir waren bis abends
gegen 17.30 Uhr unterwegs.
Auch mit den Suchhunden konnte
keine Spur aufgenommen werden,
also keine erfolgreiche Suche
durchgeführt werden.
Dann brachte die Kapo die Idee vor,
einen ihrer Partikel-Suchhunde
für die Suche einzusetzen.
Ich bin Archedio Ferrara.
Ich bin ehemaliger Polizist
der Kantonspolizei Neuenburg.
Seit eineinhalb Jahren wohne ich
mit meiner Frau in Südspanien.
Während 30 Jahren
habe ich bei der Polizei gearbeitet,
15 Jahre davon als Hundeführer.
Ich habe u.a. mit Hunden gearbeitet,
die nach vermissten Menschen suchen.
Ich wurde damals ins Wallis gerufen
wegen einer vermissten Frau.
Soweit ich mich erinnern kann,
war die Frau ungefähr 60 Jahre alt.
Es war ein deutsches Ehepaar.
Der Hund wurde dann zum Ort geflogen
und man gab ihm ein Kleidungsstück
der Vermissten, an dem er roch.
Ich ging ins Zimmer der Vermissten,
um den Geruch von ihr zu holen.
Für den Hund. Das ist sehr wichtig.
Es muss ein reiner Geruch sein.
Meist ist es ein Kleidungsstück,
das man verwendet.
Es kann aber auch ein Schmuckstück
oder gar eine Zahnbürste sein.
Such!
Dann wurden wir mit dem Helikopter
an den Ort geflogen,
wo sich der Mann und die Frau
getrennt hatten.
Dort sollte der Hund
nach der Frau suchen.
Im Gebiet,
wo sie sich getrennt hatten,
konnte der Hund
keine eindeutige Spur finden.
Die Hündin ging leider nicht los.
Sie blieb
in einem Umkreis von 200 m.
Es passierte nichts.
Das war schwierig für mich,
denn ich verstand überhaupt nicht,
warum sie nicht loszog.
Ich kann es mir
bis heute nicht erklären.
Der Hundeführer entschied dann, mit
dem Hund auf den Furkapass zu gehen,
wo sie gestartet waren.
Auf dem Furkapass, wo das Ehepaar
aus dem Postauto gestiegen ist,
wollte ich
einen zweiten Versuch starten.
Nach dem Suchergebnis am Vortag
war ich sehr skeptisch,
ob das überhaupt etwas bringt.
Der Hund schlug sofort an.
- Dann ging er wie eine Rakete ab.
Er zog direkt los in die Richtung,
wo das Paar
die Wanderung begonnen hatte.
Der Hundeführer
liess sich vom Hund mitreissen.
Ich musste sie ziehen lassen.
Ihr Tempo war zu schnell für mich.
Irgendwann später
wurden sie langsamer
und ich konnte sie wieder einholen.
Der Hundeführer sagte,
es sei sehr selten,
dass ein Hund so eindeutig anzeigt.
Der Hund nahm bei der Abzweigung
nicht den Weg,
der nach Oberwald geht,
sondern lief weiter.
Der Hund lief noch etwa
2 bis 2,5 km weiter ...
(Marco Imoberdorf)
... und lief direkt zum Bidmersee.
Und vor dem See, beim Ufer,
verlor er die Spur.
Warum ein Hund
nicht mehr weitersucht,
kann verschiedene Gründe haben.
Bei meiner Hündin z.B. war es so,
dass sie nur den Geruch finden
konnte, den man ihr gegeben hatte.
Ist die Person verstorben,
kann sie diesen Geruch
schon nicht mehr finden,
denn der Geruch eines Menschen
verändert sich kurz nach seinem Tod.
D.h., einen Kadaver
konnte meine Hündin nicht finden.
Der Hundeführer sagte dann,
so wie er seinen Hund kenne,
denke er, dass die Frau zu 99 %
bis zum See gekommen sei,
wo der Hund die Spur wieder verlor.
Ich weiss bis heute nicht, warum
der Hund da mit der Suche aufhörte.
Wenn man sich das Gelände anschaut,
dann ist es so,
dass man von dieser Stelle,
wenn man nicht weiss, wo man ist
und man sich
nicht orientieren kann ...
Man sieht von dort den Ort Gletsch.
Man sieht also Häuser,
wo abends Licht brennt.
Intuitiv würde man
in diese Richtung gehen.
Und da wird das Gelände
sehr unwegsam.
Auch für den Hund ist es schwierig,
da eine Spur aufzunehmen.
Wir vermuten,
dass sie dort zu Tode gekommen ist.
Als letztes Mittel entschieden wir,
die Öffentlichkeit einzubeziehen.
Und so informierten wir am Samstag
nach dem Verschwinden
von Frau Springinsgut
auch die Öffentlichkeit
über die Vermisstmeldung.
Die Meldung wurde in regionalen und
nationalen Medien veröffentlicht.
Das kam aus dem Nichts.
Ich dachte, sie wollen mir wohl
irgendetwas überreichen,
vielleicht Unterlagen
oder was auch immer.
Aber damit hätte ich nie gerechnet.
Nie.
Ich traf bei der Polizei ein und ...
... ich wusste noch immer nicht,
worum es geht.
Ich ging ahnungslos hin.
Ich sass dann mit
diesen Herrschaften am Tisch und ...
Das Gespräch dauerte nur kurz.
Es ging Schlag auf Schlag.
Sie sagten,
ich könne die Suche abbrechen.
Sie hätten damals einen Knochen
meiner Mutter gefunden.
Sie hätten vergessen,
diese Information weiterzuleiten.
Die Frau sei tot.
Das war wirklich brutal.
Als ich dort war ...
Dass die das so trocken sagten,
so ...
... so komplett ohne Emotionen,
wirklich nur:
"Wir haben es vergessen.
Es tut uns leid."
"So etwas kann mal passieren",
sagten sie noch.
Das war ein Fehler
der Kantonspolizei Aargau.
Wir haben diesen Fehler
öffentlich bekannt gemacht
und uns dafür entschuldigt.
"Für die Versäumnisse spricht
die Kantonspolizei ihr Bedauern,
insbesondere gegenüber
den Familienangehörigen, aus."
Das war eine grosse Panne.
Dass ein Mann nicht erfährt,
dass seine Mutter
bzw. ein Knochen seiner Mutter
gefunden wurde -
dass eine solche Information
nicht weitergereicht wird,
darf einfach nicht passieren.
Gemäss meinem Kenntnisstand
ist das der einzige Fall dieser Art.
Die Polizei steht zu ihren Fehlern,
sie macht Fehler.
Wichtig ist,
dass es nicht mehr passiert.
Aufgrund der Medienmitteilung
meldete sich
Frau Stefanie Schneiderat bei mir.
Sie war es, die damals den Knochen
am besagten Ort in Deutschland
mit ihrer Familie gefunden hatte.
Ging sie von sich aus weg
oder wegen eines Auftrags?
Das ist für mich die entscheidende
Frage bei der Beurteilung,
ob es ein Suizid
oder ein Tötungsdelikt war.
Die Antwort darauf
ist völlig unklar.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Wir kamen hierher,
mein Mann und meine beiden Söhne,
die damals ungefähr neun
und 14 Jahre alt waren.
Unser Hund war auch dabei.
Mein Sohn wollte baden gehen -
soweit ich mich erinnere, denn das
ist jetzt auch schon neun Jahre her.
Er fand dann einen grossen Knochen
an der Wasseroberfläche.
Er zeigte ihn uns und sagte:
"Guckt mal, was ich gefunden habe!"
Und wir sahen, dass er einen Knochen
in der Hand hielt,
auch der Hund hatte einen Knochen.
Ich fragte mich, ob sie vielleicht
von einem Menschen stammen.
Mein Mann meinte:
"Ach was, du liest zu viele Krimis."
Aber mir liess es keine Ruhe.
Ich machte Fotos davon.
Zwei Wochen später kam ich mit
einem Bekannten nochmals hierher,
weil es mir keine Ruhe liess.
Ich habe ihm die Knochen gezeigt.
Wir hatten sie
oben ins Gebüsch gelegt.
Er meinte, für ihn sei das eindeutig
ein Oberschenkelknochen.
Also entschied ich,
die Polizei darüber zu informieren,
sobald ich wieder zu Hause bin.
Und dann hat es sich bestätigt, dass
es wirklich Menschenknochen waren.
Da war ich natürlich froh,
dass wir es gemeldet hatten.
2017 waren wir zum ersten Mal hier.
Da traf ich dich zum ersten Mal
und du zeigtest mir die Stelle.
Es war nicht einfach, aber ...
Ich glaube,
das war ganz schlimm für dich.
Ja, das erste Mal war es schwierig.
- Ja, daran erinnere ich mich.
Ich habe viele Tränen vergossen.
Für mich war klar,
dass sie gestorben war.
Es waren ja zwei Knochen.
Ein Mensch kann ohne Oberschenkel-
knochen vielleicht schon leben,
aber dann wäre er irgendwo
im Krankenhaus gewesen oder so.
Ich hatte dennoch Hoffnung,
dass sie vielleicht trotzdem lebt.
Diese Hoffnung habe ich noch heute.
Ich weiss nicht ...
Irgendwie spüre ich das.
Aber ja ...
Es gibt noch eine Karte,
die meine Mutter unserer Tochter
aus dem Urlaub schrieb.
Das ist diese hier.
Wir fanden die Karte
in unserem Briefkasten,
als wir aus der Schweiz zurückkamen.
Auf der Karte steht:
"Liebe Antonia,
viele liebe Grüsse aus der Schweiz
senden dir sowie Mama und Papa
deine Oma Ingeborg und Opa Kalle."
Abgeschickt am 14.9.
Das war der Tag, an dem sie
auf der Furkapasshöhe wandern waren.
Um den Jahrestag herum
war die Familie wieder hier.
Das war, als wir das Kreuz
aufgestellt haben.
Sie riefen mich an
und wir trafen uns.
Sie meinten, da der Hund
die Spur am See verloren hatte,
ob man dann
nicht den See absuchen sollte.
Also organisierten wir zwei Taucher.
Der See ist ca. 3,5 m tief, von der
Fläche her ist er nicht allzu gross.
Aber die Sicht im Wasser
ist sehr schlecht.
Sie mussten alles abtasten.
Sie sahen praktisch nichts.
Doch auch das brachte nichts.
Sie fanden nichts.
Irgendwann fragt man sich dann:
"Wie viel Geld
haben wir schon ausgegeben,
und wie lange
können wir das noch durchhalten?"
Wenn eine Person
nicht gefunden wird,
tragen die Angehörigen die Kosten
und nicht die Versicherung.
Bei einem Einsatz der Kantonspolizei
Wallis in einem Vermisstenfall
entstehen
für die polizeiliche Ermittlungen
keine Kosten
für Familie und Angehörige.
Hingegen werden der Einsatz
des Helikopters und der Bergführer
in Rechnung gestellt.
Die ganze Suche hat insgesamt ...
... deutlich
über 100'000 Euro gekostet.
Irgendwann muss man sich fragen,
ob man noch mehr machen kann,
ob es bezahlbar ist.
Das war mit ein Grund,
aber nicht der alleinige.
In Absprache mit meinem Stiefvater
haben wir dann irgendwann gesagt:
"Hier ist jetzt Schluss."
Das ist eine
der letzten Wohnadressen von Gina.
Sie wohnte hier
mit ihrem damaligen Freund.
Als man ihre Spur verlor,
ging man seiner Spur nach.
Ich hatte mir erhofft, von ihm
weitere Informationen zu erhalten
hinsichtlich Marco,
vielleicht auch hinsichtlich
Marcos leiblichem Vater,
denn offensichtlich war er
zum Zeitpunkt von Marcos Zeugung
mit Gina zusammen.
Man dachte lange,
dass er Marcos leiblicher Vater sei.
Das stellte sich später
als Irrtum heraus.
Ich hatte mich bereits
damit abgefunden,
dass man meinen leiblichen Vater
nicht finden konnte.
Dann meldete sich
ein Mann aus dem Tessin.
Ich bin Aldo Bernasconi
und wohne hier in Monteceneri,
in Bironico.
Ich wohne seit 28 Jahren hier.
Ich lernte Gina 1992
in Zürich kennen.
Ich war damals im WK,
in der Nähe von Winterthur.
Ich lernte sie im Ausgang kennen.
Sie war vom Typ her sehr lebendig.
Sie war voller Lebensfreude.
Ich verliebte mich langsam in sie.
Ich fragte ihn, ob er einen
Vaterschaftstest machen könnte -
was er ohne Wenn und Aber tat.
Also haben wir den DNA-Test gemacht.
Dieser fiel leider auch negativ aus.
Das war sehr schade für mich, denn
ich verstand mich sehr gut mit ihm.
Er war mir sehr, sehr sympathisch.
Ich hätte mir gewünscht,
dass er mein Vater wäre.
Mein Ziel war es, Auskunft zu geben
sowie auch meinen Eindruck von Gina
an ihren Sohn weiterzuleiten, der
seine Mutter praktisch nicht kannte.
Ich wollte ihm zeigen,
wie seine Mutter war
und dass er auf sie stolz sein kann,
denn sie war ein toller Mensch.
Wenn wir gemeinsam unterwegs waren,
sassen wir häufig im Auto,
fuhren herum
und haben miteinander geredet.
Sie hat mir von ihrem Inneren,
ihren Träumen erzählt.
Aber auch von ihren Schwierigkeiten.
Den Schwierigkeiten,
ein normales Leben zu führen.
Das, was sie sich
eigentlich gewünscht hat.
Ich weiss nicht, ob Marco eines
Tages seinen Vater finden wird.
Vielleicht ist das aber
auch gar nicht so wichtig.
Ich kann wiederholen,
was seine Mutter sagen würde:
"Es ist nicht wichtig, was war,
wir müssen nur nach vorne schauen."
Ja ... Das wäre schön gewesen.
(Marco Imoberdorf) Ich denke, sie
muss irgendwo in diesem Gebiet sein.
(Jan André Karow) Dass sie sich
noch irgendwo dort befindet,
ist für uns gesetzt.
(Marco Imoberdorf) Ich vermute,
dass sie in einer Felsspalte liegt.
(Adrienne Bellwald) In einem Gelände
wie im Goms bzw. am Hungerberg
kann die Frau
eines Tages irgendwo auftauchen,
wo es niemand erwartet hätte.
Die Polizei, die Angehörigen,
wir alle haben gerätselt,
ob sie vielleicht
zurück zum Furkapass ging.
Man hätte von dort aus
die Furkapasshöhe
nicht mehr bei Tageslicht
erreichen können.
Per Autostopp hätte sie z.B.
vom Furkapass wegkommen
und vielleicht einem Gewalt-
verbrechen zum Opfer fallen können.
Diese Suche war speziell,
weil meine Hündin oben auf dem Berg,
wo die Frau von ihrem Mann
zuletzt gesehen wurde,
eine Anzeige hätte machen müssen.
Das hat sie aber nicht.
Das ist mir von diesem Einsatz
bis heute in Erinnerung geblieben.
Ich mag mir nicht vorstellen,
dass meine Mutter zu irgendjemandem
ins Auto gestiegen ist,
der ihr etwas Böses angetan hat.
Ein Verbrechen lässt sich nicht
mit hundertprozentiger Sicherheit
ausschliessen.
Diese Ungewissheit
bleibt bei der Familie zurück,
aber auch bei der Polizei.
Wir werden nie erfahren,
was genau passiert ist,
solange wir die Person nicht finden.
Es ging ihm nicht gut,
überhaupt nicht.
Mein Stiefvater
ist inzwischen verstorben.
Elf Jahre danach sah es im Haus
noch genauso aus wie an dem Tag,
als sie wegfuhren.
Ihre Jacke hing in der Garderobe,
ihre Handtasche - alles gleich.
Er kam eigentlich bis zum Schluss
nicht darüber hinweg.
Ich zog der Liebe wegen
nach Hannover.
Ich wohne jetzt hier.
Ich arbeite hier.
Ich habe mir hier
mein Leben aufgebaut.
Ich bin hier sehr glücklich.
Ich arbeite hier als Altenpfleger.
Mein Job besteht darin, zu schauen,
dass diese Menschen betreut sind -
dass sie zu essen bekommen
und ihr Tagesablauf geregelt ist.
Guten Tag, Frau Leibecke.
Hallo, wie geht es Ihnen?
So lala.
So lala? Okay.
Mit der Zeit entwickelt man
eine Bindung zu diesen Menschen.
Man schliesst sie ins Herz
und möchte für sie da sein.
Man belgeitet sie sozusagen
auf ihrem letzten Weg.
Die Chance, dass meine Mutter
noch lebt, ist sehr klein.
Das muss ich einsehen.
Sie ist auf jeden Fall
immer in meinem Herzen,
auch wenn ich sie nicht persönlich
kennenlernen konnte.
Sie wird stets ein Teil
von mir sein und mich begleiten.
Wenn man nicht weiss,
was passiert ist, dann ...
... weiss man im Kopf
wahrscheinlich schon,
dass dieser Mensch wohl tot ist.
Marcos Mutter spaziert
nicht irgendwo mit einem Bein umher,
und ich bin sicher,
dass Marco das auch weiss.
Aber etwas im Kopf zu wissen,
ist etwas anderes,
als diese Wahrheit
im Herzen zu glauben.
Solange er nicht
hundertprozentige Gewissheit hat -
er sagt,
das wäre z.B. ihr Schädel -,
so lange klammert er sich
an den letzten Funken Hoffnung,
dass sie vielleicht doch noch lebt.
Ich glaube, das ist menschlich.
Viele Menschen machen das,
gerade bei Vermisstenfällen.
Bei vielen Vermisstenfällen
ist irgendwann mal klar,
dass dieser Mensch nicht mehr
lebendig zurückkehren wird,
aber solange man keine Gewissheit
hat, bleibt ein Funken Hoffnung.
Langzeitvermisste sind für
die Polizei auch ein Spannungsfeld.
Aufgrund der Aktenlage
kann man aktuell nicht sagen,
was mit Marco Hauensteins Mutter
passiert ist.
Entsprechend kann ein Verbrechen
nicht ausgeschlossen,
aber auch nicht bestätigt werden.
Ich hoffte insgeheim,
dass wir doch noch herausfinden,
wer sein leiblicher Vater ist.
Auch das gehört zu Marcos Prozess:
die Frage seiner Herkunft.
Was ist vor meiner Geburt passiert?
Welches sind meine wahren Wurzeln?
Es wäre ein Teil mehr, um zu sich
selbst und um Ruhe zu finden.
Dass man bei einem Vermisstenfall
gar nichts findet -
wie im vorliegenden Fall -,
ist eher aussergewöhnlich.
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt konnten wir
alle Einsätze immer abschliessen,
weil wir die vermisste Person
lebendig oder tot finden konnten.
Doch in diesem Fall nicht.
Ich habe immer wieder Phasen,
in denen ich
an diesen Einsatz denken muss.
Der Fall ist in unseren Vermissten-
dossiers nach wie vor aktiv.
Sollten neue Erkenntnisse
oder Informationen
im Vermisstenfall Springinsgut
auftauchen,
können wir die Ermittlungen
jederzeit wieder aufnehmen.
Die Vorstellung, irgendwo zu liegen
mit Blick aufs Matterhorn -
das ist keine
so schlechte Vorstellung.
Das haben wir uns einfach
so ausgedacht und so erzählt.
Ich stelle mir das schöner vor,
als 3 m unter der Erde zu liegen.
Das ist die Version,
die wir uns zurechtgelegt haben.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023